pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon vous pouvez entrer tous les deux
évidemment non
oh je donne ces charmants cheville mais
je vous ferai visiter une autre fois si
vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient aucun
bien sûr d'alioui aux merveilles de
dépôt est ce que je pourrais me
débarrasser bon allez un petit coup de
main sont les bienvenus tenez vous venez
là vous me prenez les pieds on va le
transpondeur inquiet c'est ce qui a
envoyé un bon j'ai compris
merci pour l'info de massane feria
débrouiller tout seul à la housse
marquis n'a pas l'air très doux nom
surtout quand on ne porte pas fatigué
vous savez 70 kg multiplié par six
étages ça va tout de même cherché dans
l'est attendaient que je ne vous disent
pas bt dans les 420 kg 1 finalement je
suis désolé je ne savais pas que
l'ascenseur était en panne c'est un
miracle que nous l'ayons rencontré
personne vous ne voyez croisant à
leucate et entre deux étages non mais je
vous vois très bien m'offrant un double
scotch à titre de réparation je salue
votre conscience professionnelle que ce
qui lui vaut cet honneur
bien sûr ce qu'elle a pu en or il est
très possible
vous êtes médecin et votre sale français
a doublé scott double erreur cher
françoise et si vous prennez tranquille
voilà plus d'une heure que j'en use avec
votre permission
j'avais un peu forcé sur le champagne je
ne sais plus très bien si vite arrivé
bon alors si je comprends bien je ne
vous plait plus depuis que cette
histoire vous à l'église et les hommes
et deux femmes s'entendent ça c'est leur
charme d'être difficile et leur devoir
d'être impossible
dormez avec la plus jeunes et de femmes
du monde c'est avec une gourgandine que
vous vous réveillez non l'amour purifie
tout oser dire jamais mais oser dire que
vous me détestez ça ne regarde que moi a
doctor
je me refuse à tenir ce genre de propos
de vente à moribond on dit oui ne
respire plus c'est affreux il va mourir
chez moi marquer ses respects appelé
c'est qu'il est déjà mort mais ne vous
affolez pas
il s'est jamais aussi bien portée
trouver là il est tout de même dans le
coma mais non simplement assoupi
personne n'est jamais mort devant été
éjectée d'une voiture à l'arrêt dans un
sous bois
après avoir été un tout petit peu
assommés dévêtue et des chaussées
spectacle dont le hasard nous a gratifié
joli hasard vraiment un parfait étranger
avec qui je dîne chez des amis à meudon
client offre de me raccompagner et avec
qui je me retrouve dans un fourré du
bois de boulogne quand les culs
s'imposait rendez compte de la chance
que vous avez eu que ce parfait étranger
comme vous dites soit médecin a dit sa
peur de la chance je dois reconnaître
que j'ai eu de la chance mais comment ce
soir chez les lanciers vous auriez très
bien pu faire la connaissance d'un
ingénieur d'un militaire d'inclure dans
l'état où il se trouve
je me demande si à cuire et devrait pas
pousser fillon écoutez je suis médecin
oui ou non
bon alors je vous rassure tout de suite
un hématome sur la nuque n'a jamais tué
personne
non quand il ya fracture du crâne
l'hématome est immédiatement résorber
dans cette petite rue en connaissait
bien leur boulot ce désaveu
soigneusement enveloppé leur clé
anglaise win non je ne vois qu'une
explication à votre refus d'alerter la
police
vous aviez deviné que j'adorais la
peinture vous tenez absolument à nous
montrer votre dali support mans vous
voulez la vérité je vais vous la dire
à la lueur de vous phare j'ai cru
reconnaître dans la victime apparente
mon mari whisky et juge au tribunal de
commerce de carpentras et qui hélas est
coutumier de ce genre de fraude elle qui
monte à paris
vous avez dit j'ai cru reconnaître vous
avez donc faire c'est à dire je m'en
suis aperçu dans le hall de l'immeuble
ah bon et vous m'avez laissé monter les
six étages merci nous ne pouvions tout
de même pas le déposer devant la porte
est ouverte pour 4 m il n'est pas votre
parent donc tout va bien
mon mari va rentrer d'un moment tu as
l'eau et les jaloux je ne tiens pas à ce
qu'il le devienne moi non plus
alors soyez gentils vous m'avez bien
demandé de monter votre trousse à tout
hasard lui et que si ce nom parce ce
bonhomme tardait à se réveiller voulu
faire une piqûre qu'il remettrait
d'aplomb tout pour me faire aimer je
reviens
je pourrais trouver un peu d'eau
bouillie dans le vestibule la force et
la cuisine vous trouverez une casserole
bon 3000 tu reviens bien c'est trop
affreux et celui là qui sourit aux anges
maintenant oh non ça je veux savoir je
dois savoir monsieur monsieur à l'e
mailing ou non croyants
c'est pas beau moment
oui mais voilà quand vous appelez
françoise alors vous n'êtes pas ma mère
c'est lui en nickel s'appelle me verra
et vous ouais mais ça me revenir à j'y
suis julien julien ouffe travail ou que
sais que je suis ici mois plus tard plus
tard tout ça mais si vous la réunion à
beaubourg ouais il bosse comme une boule
de pétanque vous appelez un beau ça vous
apprendra peut me prendre à quoi à
draguer ou bois en quête de sensations
vous êtes arrêté dans une voiture où il
se passait des choses des choses intimes
vous vous êtes penché pour mieux voir et
vlan un bon couple est en baisse pour
vous rappeler aux convenances ne sais
pas ça du tout ainsi mais non d'abord
c'est pas au vol ça m'est arrivé je
travaille moi la nuit madame avait pas
au bois mais moi non plus monsieur août
ouais je suis gardien de nuit aux
entrepôts des magasin de fourrures le
grand nord à courbevoie
voyez la nuance un bon dieu mais je suis
à toi moi mes grands mots tout de suite
mon pantalon mais clé dans les salons ah
ça y est je me rappelle je me rappelle
ce qui s'est passé maintenant si c'est
un cas ce à quoi la hold up si vous
préférez 30 millions de petites coupures
la paye pour les ouvriers et toutes les
fourrures mais vous vous délirez mon ami
je délire c'est dans la cour après que
je leur ai ouvert la grille que je les
ai reçus sur la nuit tu m'as pêche
ouais mais j'avais pas de raison de me
méfier j'avais reconnu la bagnole du
comptable qui venait avec son aide
une autre caisse noire décapotable
conduite à droite
il m'avait fait les appels de codes
convenus tout sauf que j'ai trouvé
qu'ils arrivaient pas mal en avance sur
leur habituelle et il avait oublié
d'allumer le plafonnier mais ça il est
pensé une fois sur deux ils étaient
combien 2 comme toujours vous reconnais
trier vos agresseurs non la dernière
chose que j'ai eue avant qui m'a somme
c'est qu'ils avaient débat sur la figure
quelle heure est il
there et keller maintenant 00h10 voir
est loin bon je sais ce qu'il me reste à
faire
oui quoi avait raconté mon histoire au
commissariat oui oui évidemment alors si
vous aviez le téléphone
non non non je n'ai pas de téléphone non
j'attends que conakry et ouagadougou
soit équipé c'est pas malheureux ya ce
coup de gueule et non la france est 9e
plus monsieur fils jamie benn je vais
vous dire tout ça c'est de la faute à la
télé ouais depuis la télé le pays n'est
plus gouverné mars
ouais la télé ah bon vous ne vous avez
pu oublier le commissariat peut-être
qu'à votre place je ne serais pas si
près c'est pourquoi on est bien votre
espoir je n'aime pas beaucoup non plus
et on va l'aimer encore noisettes au
commissariat parce que c'est du vent
votre histoire alors vassallo et
ma pêche sur la nuque c'est du vent je
vais vous poser une question
la première qu'il vous posons pouvez
vous me dire le numéro et la voiture non
des crises et aux agresseurs mais je le
dédie il avait débat sur la tête vous
reconnaîtriez leur foi mais c'est
surtout avec leur matraque qui manque au
vert bref tout juste l'histoire que vous
racontez riez si vous étiez de mach avec
eux ma bosse elle est moche de
l'indispensable scénario spectaculaire
mais jamais fatale est plutôt uzel
scénario ils vont s'en lécher les
babines au commissariat avant de
retrousser leurs manches alors alors
vous ne serez peut-être pas bien beau
avoir deux le matin alors que si vous
aimez les coups bas en attendant je
voudrais bien savoir comment ça se fait
que je me trouve ici d'empêcher fait
vous le raconter mais en attendant il
faut vous remontez je prendrais bien une
petite tasse de café
pourquoi pas une grenadine ascot à
double scott avec quelques gouttes de
maxi temps mais que c'est quoi ça
galvanisant parce que je voudrais
pendant plus arrivé de l'inde et chez
les flics et c'est pour le coup que mon
histoire leur paraîtraient pas
catholique
ce que je prends pour rouler la nuit
paris me 108 heures ont durant cette
lucidité données cumulées moi ça que
c'est comme un seigneur
bravo compter maintenant qu'on te coin 1
2 3 etc
si la voix qui se raffermit en premier
vous allez voir une bonne chose 1 2 3 4
je peux m'asseoir à vous pouvez tout
voilà au petit bonhomme
merci monture voilà en soit ça y est
présente pour les trois mines qu'est-ce
que vous avez fabriqué moi faire
chauffer l'eau alors une autre belle
endormie comment va-t-il omettez mais il
a bougé la dir est il s'est réveillé à
bord bravo c'est l'air endormi par dont
il a parlé je n'avais pas de choix matin
le vol avait endormi mais comment vous
le non non non non très gentiment dans
un double scotch 30 gouttes de nabû
talentueux manque 30 gouttes et la dose
massive il le fallait
oui mais dites vous capable de garder un
secret c'est même une de mes spécialités
professionnelles voyez-vous les
bienvenus je vous ai menti tout à
l'heure tu oui je n'ai jamais cru
reconnaître un parent dans ce type là
non c'est la voiture d'où il a été
éjecté que j'ai reconnu la voiture de
jérôme nom marie josette sur l'endroit
n'était pas très bien éclairé vous savez
ça a vu la ville choisie un dessin je
sens on met les autres qu'ils soient ne
fournit pas non paris et en plus j'ai
reconnu notre numéro quand je sais par
coeur alors dans celui là s'est
réveillée tout trépignant de courir au
plus proche commissariat alors on leur a
volé sa voiture à votre mari des hippies
en pleine orgie collectif que cet
imbécile est allé regarder d'un peu trop
près tout c'est imbécile comme vous
dites n'a pas été matraqué dans le bois
non il s'appelle ouf
il est il est gardien de nuit dans un
entrepôt à qu'on peut voir il a été
assommé par deux gangsters qui venait
voler une paye de 30 millions et des
fourrures
après avoir piqué la voiture de votre
mariage ça aussi ça se voit tous les
jours
notre cible mon mari a à garder la
voiture ce soir pour se rendre à une
commission de recyclage au ministère du
travail les directement leurs parkings
assurés dans l'accord du ministère
ils doivent laisser leurs clés aux
surveillants oui là ça devient plus
embêtant avant que vous permettez que je
vous pose une question sur la pointe des
pieds à venir oui parce qu'il ya des
maris qui sont censés être une
commission de recyclage et qui
explication qui vous arrange c'est
surtout qu'elle écrirait vengeance qui
appelait vous standard de sous
secrétariat une passe sur le parking
après tout je peux avoir manuel numéro
c'est vrai d'ailleurs ah oui oui je
prends la ligne un message à 19h02 qui a
bon elle ne peut pas re lire le nom
écrit par sa collègue ne m'étonne pas
pop jamais pouvez-vous au moins
transmettre le message passe et encore
une chance alors 18 répété moi ça que je
la wii
oui merci mademoiselle
mais qu'est-ce qui violent jérôme est
parti d'ici après mois en mettant les
abonnés absents le message est pour lui
que monsieur dormoy ne s'inquiète pas la
marchandise sera livrée sans faute avant
20 heures chez mademoiselle mot 147 rue
des batignolles qu'ils veuillent bien
excuser ce léger retard
si je veux dire vous n'avez rien de
mauvais dans vos relations la norme ni
personne qui habite rue des batignolles
le mystère s'épaissit mais les doutes se
confirme en tout cas inutile je crois
d'appeler le standard des marchandises
machin toutes les suppositions sont
permises à du chalumeau oxydes rica la
trousse du parfait casseurs non non ce
genre peuvent pas croire que mon mari et
participé à un amateur ton mari me
semble très fort au contraire
je remets d'un faible ni magie native il
ne cesse de me répéter l'horreur de son
travail au ministère avant pour le
quitter ou vivre comme il dit il
n'attend que la mort d'une vieille tante
à 20 coups d'argent ne serait pas au mas
être impatiente et des fois vous savez
il ya des gens très convaincant pour
vous mettre des idées terrible en tête
la qu'attendez vous encore deux mois et
bien tout d'abord puis il est arrivé ici
endormi alors si leur part de même il
sera jamais qu'il est venu chez moi et
voir avare en v tandis que je peux
donner mon adresse à la police j'aurai à
lui expliquer ce que je faisais la nuit
on voit avec vous bernard oui il faut
que vous leurs appreniez hutu l'avons
trouvée avant qu'ils ne seraient que
vous voulez que j'en ramène dans le bois
bat d'aider les étages mais ce sera moi
dieu pour descendre et dans cet état là
que c'est mon mari a plein tiroirs de
vieux vêtements je vais bien lu ton bien
plus les pantalons le pos ait pu retour
vous n'aura qu'à téléphoner à la police
d'une cabine publique
elle leur a dit qu 18 et si nous nous
sommes trompés ainsi on lui a tout
bêtement voler sa voiture à votre mari
d'emma supposons le dans ce cas là je ne
veux plus vous savez très bien que je
m'envole dans vigeo pour canberra
australie pour trois ans à titre de
médecin personnel de l'honorable la vie
tchô gouverneur du pays et roi du
manganèse
écoutez bernard je vous jure que je
serai demain à 6 heures au bar de mitac
en chemise et la corde au cou en tout
cas pas en cote de maille puteaux où
allez vous chercher des vêtements
n'oubliez pas d'enlever sur la layette
le nom et l'adresse du tailleur de votre
mari ça pourrait donner des idées à la
police où ça vous avez raison car na et
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un petit mois que ce
n'est pas vrai mais quoi c'est un
directeur au ministère du travail ne
devient pas gangsters en une
j'aimerais pouvoir rassurer mais vous
avez déjà entendu parler du docteur
jekyll et de mr hyde et et pourquoi ce
serait faux pas j'ai beau mais pourquoi
pas jérôme
tu n'es pas bien très bien
les heureuses en ce moment oui je suis
pour un peu beaucoup
[Musique]
bon allez je vous laisse moi qui a fini
j'ai dit les bourgeons
tu crois que c'est vrai qu'on puisse se
plaire comme ça tout de suite on puisse
être heureux tout à coup parce qu'on est
ensemble au bon sens bois quand
l'habitude mais oui c'est la première
fois que tu viens tu penses déjà ta
seconde visite tu as pas très bientôt
des pantoufles la brosse à dents et moi
j'aurais dû trancher
pendant que nous regarderons du luxe à
la télé je suis comme ça oui en jeu
s'est enquis les choses comme ça comme
ça et puis c'est comme ça qu'on se
retrouve avec deux ménages sur le duo tu
es marié 0 1
la première fois que je t'ai rencontré
tu porte à une alliance allait ramer
l'habite
tu me fera plaisir aux deux
merveilleuses j'ai peut-être aussi moins
libre que tu ne crois qu'on savait
toujours trop loin
non ce que je veux pas c'est que tu te
compliquer la vie que tu multiplies part
de tes mensonges des alibis à on a été
heureux ensemble ce soir
oui lyon elle me croit moi je souhaite
de tout mon coeur que ça ne cause aucun
ennui d'aucune sorte pour ta femme louis
tu en ce moment une commission de
recyclage
elle pas de valeur cyclique ce soir
j'étais principal chez des amis qui
l'ont invité à dîner au château mieux
avec sage et si tu apprenais qu'elle
aussi ce soir à déguster en agréable
compagnie la langouste et du péché
les huîtres adultes année on a eu peur
ni la c1 alors ah non là je crois que je
ferai du vilain oui mais moi ces
différentes
je suis un homme oui oh ça je m'en suis
aperçu merci madame ya là voilà merci
c'est gentil
d'abord qu'est ce que tu entends par
gentil attendait atteint que je te parle
d'elle mais maintenant mon film ça ça
m'embête pas spécialement je t'avoue que
je préférais le sujet de conversation
mais si ça t'embête dont tu te sens pas
à l'aise vis-à-vis d'elle tulasne sans
doute alors je me trompe c'est pas un
bruit là puisque pitt yalaoui je laime
mais salima quoi tout ça peut-être à
m'éviter des regrets ces gens et puis
j'aimerais qu'ils lisent des choses je
croyais que les confidences monnaie
toujours trop loin c'est que moi je
t'aurais fait non mais tu peux me vois
que tu es heureux avec ma femme tu sais
je suis pas jaloux et ben oui là je suis
très heureux avec ma femme que je n'ai
jamais cessé d'aimer et qui me le rend
bien voilà je suis contente oui oui et
je te remercie toute franchise bon allez
prenez plus tant par les vannes nat
embarrasserait manteau hadid ont été
plus fringants quand tu me faisais la
cour plus papa et toi tu disais rien
mais à l'homme depuis trente ans après
il faut que je parle aux que c'est coca
je suis d'autant plus qu'avant tu es
très silencieux je vais presque
mystérieuse est ce que tu me trouves
mystérieuse préservant un peu de mystère
on y gagnera hier
il ya un homme dans ta vie où ça j'en ai
peur c'est une pré s'est jetée à
répondre écrivent pas bon je pense
rapide question aussi vie je peux au
moins tu appelé non oui mais pas avant
la semaine prochaine
parfait parfait pour ces patients et
disciplinés sénou perrière non non et
ben alors mais ça y'est pas vraiment
petit poulet de grain au revoir à la
semaine prochaine
allô allô tonio mission accomplie il
vient de sortir enfin minuit et demi je
suis dans les temps bon ça va me
remercie pas
je me sens pas tellement fiennes quoi a
l'air de regretter
enfin pas si seulement j'avais clair non
stop à l'andouille
bah oui je suis qu'une femme aux seins
je sais que ce genre de sentiments
t'échappe bon saveurs assure toi j'ai
toujours la tête sur les épaules c'est
pas un petit coup de coeur à faire des
folies
je vais raccrocher parce qu'il va pas
tarder à remonter ciao topic pas oublié
quelque chose a pris ma voiture que je
ne retrouve pas c'est ici que tu vient
la chercher
tu sais plus où tu l'agavé mais s'ils
vont 151 la place de la camionnette deux
premiers qui repartait c'est un milieu
où la faune qui en affiche plus les
voitures en les ans je m'excuse race et
une subtilité qui met shocked l'instant
mais ça veut dire que tu la retrouvera
bientôt voici sept heures le vol à la
police wayne et alors ça va pas
déclencher le plan orsec tu sais non
mais ça obligera précisé le lieu de sa
disparition pas un si tu vois comme
c'est difficile de tromper sa femme pour
pichet et tu voulais en tempête devrait
en revanche parce que j'ai pas que rory
la tête à réfléchir je sais écoute moi
tu vas rentrer bien sagement chez trois
taxis faire la bise à madame et au dodo
mais c'est seulement demain matin que tu
t'apercevras du vol de ta voiture que tu
auras laissé en bas de chez toi rentre
cette nuit et ben alors tu pourras aller
tout tranquillement signalé sa
disparition comme il saria de ton
quartier
tous sont plus montgueux louis quand la
police l'a retrouvera à dieu
ou les voleurs ont abandonné mon vieux
tu crois pas qu'ils vont laisser leur
carte sous l'essuie glace en mentionnant
la date et le lieu du vol sens assez
fort à la piètre si les femmes et n'est
pas capable de vous tirer débat dans
lequel vous vous mettez la vie serait
impossible
notre instinct maternel rien plus tu as
une station de taxis dans l'avenue à
droite là un petit peu plus loin et
merci beaucoup du pop tête on appelait
le minutes il à c't'heure site aura que
l'embarras du choix tu pourra même
choisir la couleur
oui on remonte petits poulets temps fut
plus je t'en supplie de me dis moi au
moment où tu travailles à l'archevêché
seigneur
tu lis trop
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
allô allô sylvie mixer mois jérôme au
haut du corps mais déjà on je demande
pardon mais il fallait absolument que je
te dise bon ben on est sûr de ne pas
recommencer
mais sitôt que j'allais voir une émotion
oui j'ai retrouvé ma voiture juste
devant chez moi et les le cap ou encore
tiède est incroyable non mails il dévie
le tir le taxi qui me ramenait m'a
déposé juste derrière non non non non
pas et ce quinté non non pas une
égratignure
non non ils n'ont même pas volé ma vie
n'y est pas facile avec les papiers dans
la boîte à gants qui ça ma femme
ben oui elle a le double des clés
février les laveries et tu crois que
c'était loin mais ne vois pas d'autre
explication
oui mais pourquoi juste devant chez moi
à peut-être raison mais comment ces bons
soins
bonsoir bonsoir ma chérie
comme durant de retard et la banda les
prévenus n'étaient pas comptés qu'est ce
que tu as tu ne semble pas dans son
assiette
une idée comme ça tu es tu ou pas je te
suis tout à fait non oh non on va
et il ta soirée au banal tu sais rien a
dit aulas jamais ce soir j'ai compris
que ce n'était pas fait pour moi aussi
fonctionner ben alors démissionne mais
de quoi vivre aux nouvelles mais ma
chérie à part tout l'argent qu'ils ne
demanderaient de crédit fabien soit pas
dans les ministères
évidemment faux fossé faut foncer faut
risquer la prison par exemple pourquoi
pas la guillotine ah non audacieux mais
pas téméraire ton mari enfin ça ne te
plaît pas droite on viole toutes a vu la
super cannes
ah non non il faudra de choisir une
autre femme ont peut-être là tu déjà
rencontré tu vas chercher et à trouver
une place juste devant la maison
oui oui pourquoi pour rien tu ne me
demande pas comment c'est passé ma
soirée chez les l'antienne à si j'en ai
le faire et bien puisque tu insistes
très agréablement suzanne était très en
beauté georges intarissable comme
d'habitude un séduisant garçons de leurs
amis a offert de me raccompagner à vie
oui je les mêmes invités à boire un
verre ah bon
c'est tout ce que tu trouves à dire
et à raccompagner en voiture bien sûr
pas sur son dos
quelle drôle de question pourquoi nous
parles tu te vois tu tu manques tu n'as
pas une petite idée
j'en ai des tas elle se bousculent et je
vais vite en faire profiter d'abord si
tu ne fais pas de 5-fu comme si j'étais
mange en poste à l'homme par accompagner
il m'a fait la cour mais mes machines
mais ma chérie du jeu jolie comme tout
et ça doit arriver tous les jours ce
temps les faits un état permanent auquel
je ne prête même plus attention mais qui
d'ordinaire ne semble pas
particulièrement réjoui et si tu fais
preuve aujourd'hui de tant
d'indifférence
c'est parce que tu as l'esprit ailleurs
des neutrons même et bien sûr mais bien
sûr et pour te prouver mon indifférence
et bien faire une surprise à sa fin a
pas encore le yacht qui la vident la
super canon mais la veste de vison blanc
que je t'avais promise pour cet hiver au
diable le calendrier tu l'auras comme
voilà là qu'est ce qui t'arrive tonnes -
whisky doublé sec
non c'est pour rire non avant tu sais ce
que coûte une veste devises en blanc en
moins que ce que tu vaux ma chérie alors
c'est parce qu'il vient mais ma chérie
louima françoise tiens ma chute mazette
bon point écoute moi bien géré ou oui ma
chérie je sais ce que tu as fait ce soir
parce que j'ai fait ce soir ne fait pas
le messie la 147 rue des batignolles du
collège et la voiture n'est pas rentré
tout seul ah bah justement je me
demandais quoi au nom du ciel jérôme tu
te demande tu donnes de garder pour toi
au bord de l'irréparable mieux vaut se
comprendre à demi mot c'est ton avis
jospeh rhétorique l'ofppt notre région
heureuse que tu entendes yan tu
reconnais avoir commis ce soir une chose
moyens le mot est dur
tu en feras non non non pas tu te
conviennent j'en ai peur mais une chose
impensable de la part d'un homme comme
toi comme tu en as bon bien se connaître
on se réserve parfois des surprises à
l'audience je crois qu'ils feraient bien
de changer de ton crâne est marrant je
regarde trop long je ne craque pas ma
chérie alors au nord n'a pas l'air dont
étouffé mais qu'est ce que tu me j'ai
fait une bêtise bon je te demande pardon
bêtise c'est le seul bêtise
oui ou non as tu l'intention de
recommencer
je te jure que non c'était la première
fois sur m'appelle françoise le cynisme
de m'offrir vison blanc mais
comprends-tu malheureux que sans parler
d'autres risques sur lesquels je préfère
penser au françois
et même quitte pour la peur crois que
j'accepterais de vivre avec un homme qui
a régné tout sens moral en rupture de
ban avec sa conscience au point de me
suis comblé ou plus abjecte turpitudes
est-ce que tu n'exagère pas un tout
petit peu c'est pas moi j'étais sans
doute là de notre afin de ma vie banale
réglé d'avancé
je suis peut-être à l'âge critique -
avaient l'occasion se présentait je
céder au vertige ma voix je pense pas
que ça fera la première page dans les
journaux et ça suffit eh bah bravo
mais si au moins tu m'en avait parlé
avant
comme à ton ami la plus sûre la plus
compréhensive j'aurais trouvé les mots
qu'il fallait
et même si je ne les avait pas trouvés
devant l'inévitable j'aurais préféré que
tu m'emmènes avec toi
qu'en pense à mon sens non
ça t'étonne j'aurais jamais soupçonné
sans toi
que tu me connais mal aux heures
difficiles ma place était ton côté bon
si vous aviez de l'ue noah bien entendu
ça aurait sûrement eu très peur mais
avec toi véro très peur tu sais pourquoi
ne me dis pas que déjà blasé battue on
doit tirer de cette aventure toutes les
sensations qu est-ce qu on t'aime
reviens nous sommes de bien que tu ne
pouvais pas les éprouver ici non mais tu
sais que tu sais que tu m'épates
vraiment je t'admire à athus n'est pas
une épouse ordinaire n'empêche que mon
premier mouvement puisque le mal était
fait a été d'appeler la police la police
ou alors tu te vois avec les menottes en
cour d'assises
aulas tu voit grand enfin un homme de ta
situation car ce une bonne éducation qui
a tout ce qu'il faut sous la main pour
être heureux la justice ce serait du de
faire l'exemple dû tomber ce soit dans
un effroyable engrenage jérôme sous une
influence fatah et là tu en as sans
doute éprouvé une jouissance exaltante
et c'est bien ça le spa
alors prêt zone est pas ma chérie je
dois t'avouer que ça nous ça n'a pas été
tellement désagréable réjouissances
criminelle a voulu tout tout pour que tu
me pardonnes match et organes de presse
je veux d'abord que tu sais ces
fréquentations immédiatement brutalement
oui françois plus de rue des batignolles
de s'affoler le signe à ses propos et eu
certains de pouvoir reprendre sa liberté
aussi facilement qu'un jour tu seras
relancer ces gens là sont capables de
tout mais qui ne laissera pas seul je
t'aimerai cours tu as déjà beaucoup fait
ma chérie je vois mieux à fait oui quoi
par exemple tirait demain si j'obtiens
dragon gastronome à chaque rencontre
sera très pénible en pourquoi tu as un
projet au nom de notre amour tu te
souviendras toujours de ce que j'ai fait
pourquoi est il aura plus jamais envie
de recommencer le vanhivax events dessus
cda pour oublier les victimes utile
parce qu'il faut pour ta santé d'abord
enfin regarde-toi oui je ne tiens pas de
voir revenir abîmé ses expéditions aux
non pêcheurs
ça c'est fait maintenant on va dormir
oui je sais pas s'il va dire ça j'ai ma
chérie tu ne viens pas à nankin pub ça
est ce que je peux te poser une question
comment as tu un homme a parlé que ça
suffise oui heureusement ce qu'il sait
ou rien oui tu as raison mon lit
jamais jamais jamais j'aurais pensé tout
le hilton
passez-moi la chambre du docteur carney
merci ses fondateurs oui bon d'accord
c'est vous bernard il est rentré il a
avoué tout ah oui alors je dois faire
quelque chose et je compte sur vous non
pas de gaudriole je vous en prie je
viendrai vous prendre demain matin à 10
heures non pas maintenant tout de même
oui enfin je vous expliquerai en chemin
en tout cas gardez moi votre matinée
merci bernard bonne nuit à j'y pense
soyez armés oui on ne sait jamais merci
au fait pourquoi ça je vais te découper
pendant ce mois d'abord c'est de la
musique pure des trappeurs at on peut
voir au cours de l'année dernière les
ateliers entrepôt garderie de la maison
de fourrure le grand nord ont été
dévalisés les malfaiteurs se sont enfuis
emportant à lots de fourrures précieuse
et 30 millions destinés à la paie du
personnel
plus tard dans la nuit à la suite d'un
coup de téléphone anonyme
le gardien de nuit a été trouvé son
connaissance dans un fourré du bois de
boulogne
il parle de la trace d'une contusion
véniel chapeau à la base du crâne et a
tenu à la police des propos incohérents
la police ne vois rien d'autre à retenir
des propos extravagant de la victime que
ces bons antécédents met hors de cause
wen empêche qu en douce ils vont lui
filer deux ou trois cours des autres et
alors alors rien c'est par des chiffons
quoi le casque on en comptait satire il
ya soit bien j'ai fait comme tu m'as dit
ouais étant la futur plein la vue avec
ses huîtres et sa langouste âme je
l'avais invité à dîner chez moi il a été
très correct dû voir que tu t'es pas
envoyer en l'air avec lui et alors ça me
regarde non c'était pas dans le contrat
tu avais dit de l'amuser pas plus c'est
pas d'alain steve d'amuser un homme
pendant trois heures en faisant état
c'est des petits pois
d'ailleurs je vois oui il ne m'a pas
ennuyer non plus et a donné combien ma
vie dont je fais pas partie d'un cheptel
alors il t'a rien à faire du doubs six
le maximum
la moitié de sa vie les mariés au assure
toi j'ai refusé je croque dedans toile
de chalets pas aussi picorer dans son
chéquier et a pas eu la langue trop
longue mais parce que rappelle toi ça
serais tu as fait un message en date est
retenue
j'ai marché dans la combine uniquement
parce que tu m'avais rendu un circuit en
plus trois briques au partage alors une
fille a bien droit de vouloir faire sa
vie non web en afrique est déjà là et a
plus que celui des fourrures à faire
rentrer trois jours galaxy a tout le
temps de perdre dans la nature comme
convenu comme si c'était fait j'ai
qu'une parole parole mais dis toi bien
que si tu ouvres et si seulement tu
l'auras voile mec de cette nuit chalach
et pas avec un lance pierres si je me
fais bien comprendre
d'accord mais je te préviens la
prochaine fois tu t'adresses railleur
parce que passe encore que je me mouille
par gratitude dans un cas sans histoire
mais avec pétards ou matraques à la clé
moi je marche pas tiens je m'entends
bien tiré mais trois ans à la roquette
c'est justement deux kilos à perdre
et la lecture à rattraper tu attends
quelques uns n'ont personne on va jamais
sonné de mon regard du royaume j'aime
mieux savoir quelque chose qui jane à
huy la bêtise mais chaque grille a nommé
une femme je les ai jamais vus tomber
bien sûr bon j'avoue le grand rabbin et
la reine d'angleterre où je pense à côté
6 5 ans fut pas long feu les artistes tu
ne laisses épinglé à quoi tu t'es fait
un café tabac lancée après usage
qu'est-ce que tu risques aïssou madame
monsieur en a tous
la vaillante et en dessous le médecin à
côté de quel étage vous trompez vous
vous êtes mademoiselle mots oui
sylvie mots exacts en rien à une amie
commune
non vous brûler un ami commun qui
s'appelle jérôme un bain japonais poids
à mon avis c'est un de trop
je suis madame jérôme dormoy
monsieur la campagne oui bah ça vous me
diriez le contraire
êtes vous seul vous le voyez au cas où
vous ne seriez pas sûr monsieur est armé
non françois bon non rassurez vous elle
très vaguement vous avez juste juste
pour la forme
papa je gagne dans mon sens pourriez
vous me dire ce qui me vaut la surprise
de votre visite
c'est très simple je sais ce que jérôme
a fait cette nuit
moi aussi comprenez-moi demi mots je
sais tout ce qu'il a fait bâle bien
raconter ça pas de vous ennuyer envoyé
bernard c'est une femme terrible je ne
peux pas dire que ça saute aux yeux
merci mais y'a pas de quoi pardon je
veux avant tout savoir comment vous êtes
arrivé à faire commettre amar est une
folie impensable
oui d'accord vous êtes jaloux pour ce
genre de folie salette
vous savez
sans doute l'avez vous fait boire mon
dieu il y avait du kirsch dans la
charlotte avec de pierres chaudes drogue
je suppose a avec tout nier faut
s'attendre à tout premier met pas dedans
il a bien fait les choses menu très
classique belon et langouste thermidor
mais vous oubliez un charlot paix et
nous avons bien failli ne pas déguster
figurez vous que le livreur l'avait
oublié défaillance rv à table vous avez
sans doute eu à déplorer un léger retard
dans la livraison de la marchandise à là
on ne peut plus rien vous cacher je vous
ne croyez pas si bien dire
et en commandant jérôme à vue le goût il
s'enfonce elle colle à la peau vous
voyez bernard nous tirerons rien de
cette lettre je veux rappeler que ce
n'est pas ce que vous êtes venu faire
c'est exact toronto mais bien vous aimer
l'argent à je ne plains pas et moi je
tiens à mon mari ça vous seriez
difficile mais je voulais rendu jusqu'au
jour l'occasion se présentera de le
remettre à l'ouvragé
car je suppose que ce qui s'est passé
cette nuit n'était pas une nouveauté
pour vous non ça franchement
eh bien avec lui plus jamais je suis
prête à vous dédommager excusez moi mais
comment l'entendez vous contre votre
promesse franche et loyale de femme à
femme déguerpir immédiatement sans
chercher à le voir contre 5 millions
cash anciens il y en a tant dit vous
êtes stupides bernard 5 millions mais je
n'irai pas au delà
longtemps plaie vous êtes vivre de vous
choisir un autre partenaire nous mais
dites moi vous n'exigez pas que des fans
le voile noir il y aura grand pitié
royaume de france vous en prie
je te rappelle toute chose si vous usiez
démons marc une seconde fois je serai
sans pitié mais est il au courant de
votre démarche
non je fais cette offre à son insu pour
le son n'est pas ce qu'il a pu vous
faire mais vous n'allez pas dire qu'il
vous est à ce point indispensable
il manque d'expérience je le connais il
n'aurait pas de mètres alentours des
hommes et des gants dit lui c'est un
amateur
vous êtes une professionnelle a pas but
je vous en prie c'est bien moi n'a pas
voulu vous être désagréable bien sûr pas
fâché je ne peux pas croire que j'ai
remarqué une chose pareille aux
madmoizelles songer à son avenir sur la
prenais à son bureau à quel jeu il se
livre dans la clandestinité faut rien
exagérer on s'est bien amusés d'accord
mais enfin on a quand même pas franchi
le mur du son
la mademoiselle je crois que vous prenez
la chose un peu trop à la légère envoyée
enfin si g rand malgré sa promesse
devait recommencer je n'hésiterai pas
une seconde
j'avais retiré la police leur enfance il
a connu la police oh là là vous y allé 2
0 leur est en prison ils n'auraient
après tout que ce qu'ils méritent
ruisseau dans le fait il a quand même
pas commis un crime qui sont les
familles peut heureusement pour docteur
était là vous êtes médecin
je suis médecin vie ah bah oui donc mais
comment vous avez voulu mourir moi bon
j'aime mieux ça en nous toute façon
soyez rassurés je le reverrai pas votre
mari a alors vous acceptez moindre chez
pas c'est à dire que 5 millions ça donne
à réfléchir
ça fait un drôle de cachot d'oseille
surtout cash et sans tva et en plus
pourraient travailler déjà fait vous
savez moi j'ai jamais tiré d'argent d'un
homme le sud une femme que vous le tirer
et simplement pour balancer un amateur
voilà c'était déjà fait on le coupable
ne revient toujours sur les lieux du
crime
alors je vous donne 24 heures pour filer
oui le temps pour moi de réunir la somme
demain même heure nous serons ici avec
le cas jour comme vous dites
et comme je pense que vous n'avez pas
invité mon mari a participé à votre sort
au tri sans lui avoir promis quelques
miettes du gâteau
je vous laisse bien entendu sa part du
butin mais que voulez vous dire
il y avait tout de même 30 millions dans
le coffre de l'entrepôt plus des
fourrures
il a eu le toupet de me promettre à
vison blanc où il garderait aussi ça
vous ira très bien mademoiselle à demain
félicitations
non bien sûr c'est le père noël qui leur
a tout raconté citée chirurgie jure qua
non de dieu encore plus que tu as
peut-être peur et tout à medica s'est
traduit passé tu me l'a pas dit tout à
l'heure que tout y était entré qu'à
reculons dans notre safari
alors pour jamais il est à petit
conscience t'as rien trouvé de mieux que
tout ton cas dans la course et macau
relation le paletot seulement pour le
coup de la musique tu repasseras il est
copain aussi
crois moi j'ai rien dit cagnotte
mais s'il y avait une autre explication
mais oui pendant que j'étais dans la
cuisine à couper le pain qui est la
salade ci s'était approché de la fenêtre
et qu'ils aient vu jjm hommes ont volé
sa voiture il pouvait pas téléphoné à la
police mais qu'il était en flagrant
délit je sais que ça à [ __ ] en l'air
s'est vu sur moi et bien la boucle et
seulement lui aussi la légion nous ce
matin et à l'époque la police disent pas
tout et la face et le morceau à sa femme
pour amortir les retombées voilà mais là
tu tiens peut-être quelque chose on a
encore une chance pétain combien ça va
rassure toi et diront rien j'imagine que
jérôme est mouillé dans le coup sa femme
un fer 5 millions pour qu'on laisse
tranquille
mais pour autant rien dans la tronche
écoute moi bien
tout a été préparé avec le plus grand
soin chaque détail était vu et revu
chaque phase de l'opération était
répétée jusqu'à plus soif
pour ne pas laisser aux flics le moindre
indice repérables mais microscope
bon ici par des coups comme ça en
laissant des trucs au hasard et voilà
des gaziers lâchés dans la nature est
capable d'aller casser le morceau
premier flic qui leur tombre a sous la
main mais encore heureux que tu peux pas
appeler pour les présentations seulement
toi ils connaissent
et toi tu nous connais tu piges au mais
alors qu'est ce que je dois faire moi
d'abord tu ramasses les cinq briques
demain et qui fait bien gaffe parce
qu'elle marchera dans le secteur pour le
partage des mappers candidats question
et acheteurs étaient dans les clous
jean-françois 11 heures comme prévu
vient poser ne plaisante pas et
lymphomes dormi comme un plan avec un
sourire à claques
il est porté à l'habitude d'utiliser
c'est pas une perfide albion ce n'était
pas une bonne idée jeter les fondations
y est bonne chose vous avez lu les
journaux
maintenant il est prêt sur son chemin
c'est une histoire est incroyable
ici vous disais que ça n'est pas tout
bon qu'est-ce qui est encore ce matin
oui ce matin pendant que jérôme dormait
j'ai pris les clés je suis descendu à la
voiture j'ai inspecté à fondre j'ai été
gâté ah bon pourquoi j'ai trouvé s'est
trouvé dans le coffre arrière coincé
dans le cric ses morceaux tout ce qu'on
veut de l'urml qu'ils ont dû arracher
précipitamment en vie dans le coffre
évidemment il n'y a pas que la spa qui
aurait son mot à dire bon alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait nous pas de changement
programme alors dans ce cas mission
accomplie oh merci bernard vous êtes un
type merveilleux mais non c'est vraiment
qui vous embrasse restez vous entendez
j'en serais charme et aux balles alors
en son absence permettez moi
m
et elle embrasse comme ça mais bon sur
mon dos quant à ma grand-mère alors vous
ne m'obligez pas à la gifler et
parlez-moi plutôt de ma tante
maintenant on attend toujours prétendre
que c'est sa petite famille voilà un
million de juste ce que vous souhaitiez
vous et merci
s'ils n'ont pas été étonnés qu'on veut
ni engager un collier perdu tout je leur
ai dit que je ne le pensais plus depuis
un petit moment
la confiance règne vous savez aucun
voleur de ça c'est bête pourrait leur
porter le fruit de sa récolte c'est chez
eux que la police et les assurances
vient de se renseigner en premier à vous
en savez des choses que je suis abonnée
au reader's digest
dites moi votre mari ne va pas s'étonner
de la disparition de votre collier non
non ça fait des mois que je ne porte
plus moi le père en fils et père que je
vois pas ce qu'il pourrait dire je n'ai
pas mis au clou pour quoi c'est frais
c'est en fait le reçu c'est un papier ne
pas laisser traîner non il est en sûreté
pour le moment je préfère le dernier bon
maintenant que détenait voilà j'ai pas
eu le gpu lecoeur vc japonais des
paniers aux cubaines
quand j'ai vu leur rible grosses pattes
de l'employé s'avance et j'ai eu le
petit frisson des mauvaises actions j'ai
pas pu mon enfant est idiot bernard m'a
peut-être mais rien ne donne
l'impression d'aimer comme de faire
quelque chose d'idiot ou plutôt quelque
chose qui serait idiot si si l'on
n'avait pas mais alors cet argent donc
ma part je n'ai pas besoin avant trois
en cinq ans peut-être
et puis qu'est ce que seront devenus mes
pauvres petits francs quand je les
retrouverai vous savez savez vous
bernard qu'il faudrait que vous me
plaisait beaucoup pour que j'accepte
mais mais c'est là que j'ai perdu
vous me voyez faisant la cour à une
femme qui croiraient me de voir quelque
chose
non c'est pas mon genre ça non c'est
simplement une bouée de sauvetage que je
vous lance maintenant pourquoi vous ça
parce que je vous aime françoise tout
simplement qu'emportez-vous dans six
jours à 800 kilomètres heure à 8000
mètres d'altitude c'est plutôt rassurant
c'est un nombre apparemment oui
dites-moi si j'arrive à voir matt enfin
la vraie à lovren avant
vous reprendrez votre argent à la mort
dans l'armée alors vu l'urgence on
accède remercie françois alors ça c'est
le plus beau cadeau que vous puissiez le
faire les élus ont pas encore tout à
fait prêt quoi qu'est ce qui vous manque
et bien je peux plus maintenant vous
plaît santé je vous crois très attendu
je sais c'est quelque chose que je
voulais vous demander
oui mais vous venez d'être si bien je
n'ose plus moi mais vous allez osé tout
de suite oui mais je vous assure qu'elle
est très regardable
enfin de rap être pas seul qui aura fait
des sales types avec elle ses complices
sont soutenus personnellement je ne
crois pas si bête souvenez vous elle
était seul quand vous lui avez fait
votre proposition
ça m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'elle invite
ses petits amis qui doivent être très
gourmand au moment de la distribution
même si ça ne me donne pas la chair de
poule et électrices
alors on saute si je comprends bien il
ne vous déplairait pas que jai saut
après ce que vous venez faire pour moi
je n'ai pas le droit de vous demander
non mais j'ai le devoir de l'accepter
non bernard et bien c'est chose faite
françoise merci bernard du fond du coeur
mais derrière madame bernard oui je ne
viendrai pas où hilton ce soir mais dans
six jours
ayez fait toutes vos courses je passerai
vous dire adieu
moi je fais là bon je sais que je
demande pardon j'ai pas pu attendre il
fallait que je te vois je me cieux à
viège
comment monsieur tu ne me reconnais pas
absolument pas l'objet de votre visite
aussi c'est ce qui inquiète rassure toi
je le fais pas c'est d'ailleurs je ne
peux jamais me sentais bien longtemps de
mon bureau non mais des droits qui
croyez vous parlez vous vous trompé de
porte voix y ait un petit peu dans les
étages au dessus des arrêtes de faire
l'idiot je crevais tout simplement dans
victoire et surtout de t'apporter
souvenir d'une merveilleuse soirée euros
ce qu'une bêtise mille regrets mais ne
concerne pas on regarde de loin
non j'ai alors c'est toujours non pas
personnellement henry ou mais attendez
posé ça là je prends connaître la
personne à qui vous destiniez ce petit
souvenir je me ferai un plaisir de lui
faire parvenir
j'espère qu'elle sera content elle sera
difficile mais vous faites pas
d'illusions elle part pour un grand
voyage avec vous exact ne faisant qu'une
vont relier ensemble
oui si nos enseignants avec des ciels
regard et vous fait mille commission dit
me téléphone est bien vite mais à mon
bureau pas chez moi ma femme c'est tout
à ça je sais qu'elle sait tous comment
refuser
elle a bien volé mon informés et aussi
me faire promettre de ne plus revoir
verte a téléphoné mieux que ça elle m'a
même rendu une petite visite et les
vallées et le rire est venu ici elle
m'avait dit qu'elle le ferait et c'est
pour ça que tu pars tient dix mois mais
mon petit canard des lieux a raconté ne
savez pas tout toutefois elle savait
tout tout tout tout mais a dit qu'elle
voulait que je dise je pourrais pas nier
l'évidence
ma voiture n'est parvenu tout seul alors
c'est elle qui l'a ramenée lt l'a pas
dit elle me l'a pas dit mais qui veux-tu
que ce soit notamment atteint si non je
ne sais pas il m'a suivi où elle m'a
fait filmer je vois pas d'autre
explication
pourquoi elle avait des soupçons bon ben
là mais alors comment est elle si ton
nom ton nom et ton adresse et comprend
rien toute cette histoire
dis moi elle m'a menacé et c'est pour ça
que tu peux maintenant qu'est-ce que tu
vas chercher
j'avais déjà des fourmis dans les jambes
la patiente elle m'a parlé a décidé à
partir enfin web pour la forme je vais
demander 24 heures pour réfléchir
d'ailleurs je la tends à penser à tant
qu acteur qui l'attend pas mais c'est
évident que je l'attends mais non
impossible après tout la parole sa
masseuse tous les vendredis qu'elle t'a
dit non au festin des jugements dernier
plus pour que de la fin de toute façon
ça ne change rien à ma décision mondou
cher monsieur que je ne connais pas qui
vous êtes trompé de forts niveaux vous
en aurez quand heureuse à non j'ai
promis à ta femme donne plus te voir tu
es ton dernier bon oui le dernier
convenable à dieu jérôme bon j'insiste
pas aux messieurs
anne auriez vous laissez à bons
souvenirs à une inconnue voilà j'ai
toussé faut bien rappeler une pop in
cape est en dessous alors pendant que
j'ai fait un saut si ça vous ennuie pas
en vous en allant ou des poseriez ses
deux valises chez la concierge elle pèse
pas lourd ce sera ça traite chevalerie
avant attendez la petite boîte et que
vous avez apporté c'était sûrement dans
l'idée de jouer les prolongations au une
erreur quoi alors des fois que ça vous
gênerait de l'apprendre devant moi c'est
plus loyal de vous laisser une chance un
parole d'honneur je comprendrais mais
pour kim prenez louche c'est un homme
tenez compter jusqu'à 10 avant de filer
comme ça vous n'aurez pas de regrets et
moi pas de remords jurés oui à la pas ne
tirez pas la porte surtout sinon je me
retrouverais son panier
or
je peux entrer
vous êtes à mana
vous êtes un ami de mademoiselle reiss
était décédé cet été c'est exagéré part
en voyage des sens et c'est baba bâ
c'est un frère vous êtes sont fondés de
pouvoir c'est que c'est pas que je suis
dans sa bouche mais non mais non mais je
sais qu'on n'est jamais très bavarde
votre branche ça peut ça va bien oui non
mais ça va comme ça si vous voulez la
voir et je me suis moi même que à bien
vous êtes donc il ya des circonstances
où les eaux les contacts directs ne
s'impose pas pas plus que les
présentations rencontre
non le principal concours
le principal pour moi c'est que je
puisse le laisser ça ici il faut qu'elle
le trouve à son retour
voyez ces riens qui sait rien qu'il est
là qu'il assure comme l'a d'ailleurs ce
sont des commandes
ce sont elles les papiers à ce moment
les causes sont les papiers ce que les
patients n'aient pas c'est qui ce sont
les sur les papiers convenu oui si on
est parti à san luca qui vous voyez ce
que ça pas du tout vous voulez vérifier
la non non c'était une fille non
proposées dont salah est à 5 ans filles
elle le verra en arrivant prix pas tout
le plaisir sera pour m écoutez monsieur
c'est par vous faire des compliments
mais franchement on vous donnerait le
bon dieu sans confession voulait pas du
tout le physique de l'emploi
bon pas bon mais je ne saisis pas bien
mais je n'insiste pas et vient de le
petit beau de le petit bout de deux
rouges la la la bretagne et chapeau
pour qu'ils diable le match pourri celui
là
le qg
qu'est-ce que cela
eh ben
évidemment je ne faisais pas le poids
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tranquille cinq minutes entre est
toujours au madame je vous remercie
moi dans mon dieu mais je vous dérange
non non je dormais enfin plutôt
j'essayais mais une pièce à paris bon je
suis désolé vous annonçant prix
expliquez-moi puis tout ce que vous
venez faire ici chez moi comme vous
m'aviez promis de filet mais madame je
serai loin cette news les pros que ce
que je réussis à ce mélange marc et
croqueuse choristes un surnom tonio les
croqueuses il en a quatre en or massif
votre employeur je suppose alors je vous
préviens si vous renvoie à la charge pas
un centime de plus 5 millions pour un
harry passablement usagers on n'a jamais
vu ça même à galliera alors la porte à
titre non madame
si vous refusez de m'écouter qu'est ce
que je vais devenir moi c'est votre
problème j'ai les miens mais madame
chaussures danger demeure vous tant qu'à
faire il courage de mourir debout je
voulais pas prier pour s'asseoir je n'ai
pas fait exprès j'ai plus de jeunes en
soi n'exagérez pas si j'y vois clair il
vous reste deux années du vent ma petite
mais quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est parce
qu'il est la musique si méchante qui il
bat marie oger suis dit oui vous devrez
aussi à domicile on aime madame vous
avez ma promesse de ne plus voir s'il
est ici je m'en vais tout de suite il
est sorti mais leur venir c'est pareil
aller où bon les bains adieu madame à
dieu et puis je vous fais remarquer que
lorsque vous êtes venu chez moi je ne
savais pas invité je vous ai mieux reçus
c'est juste et pourtant je faisais
croire que vous veniez me casser la
figure
c'est réellement moi que vous venez voir
madame je vous le jure
soit vous donne 10 beau pas en plus au
bon alors c'est quoi la peine même pour
envoyer un télégramme je m'en tire
jamais à moins de 2000 bol
cinq minutes c'est dans vos prix je peux
essayer
bon là madame attention ma petite a fait
très attention je vous ai versé une
somme assez douillette pour déguerpir
je comprends bien ça vous a mis l'eau à
la bouche mettez vous pensez avoir tout
à gagner et rien à perdre en essayant de
secouer l'arbre un peu plus une petit
chantage à épisodes à rallonge montée
probablement avec vos complices dans ce
cas je vous préviens rien à faire j'ai
payé une fois pour sauver un malheureux
égard est plus faible et beaucoup pas
que vous avez peut-être celui de force
avant de lui arracher son consentement à
partager vos sinistre instinct province
a alors vite tout de suite que je les ai
eus au karaté me surprendrait pas
jusqu'à preuve du contraire vous n'avez
eu entre vos mains qu'un instrument
passif un instrument passiez ben j'ai
pas envie de rire
ça va passer car sachez bien une chose
si votre victime comme été la folie de
vous revenir et de récidiver je ne cours
pas après ma mise vous refais ma vie en
mieux et vous laisserai la tâche
hebdomadaire de lui apporter des réseaux
orange est il aussi à métaux dans une
baguette viennois dites moi mais ça vous
arrive jamais de laisser parler les
autres on m'avait promis cinq minutes je
peux soit tous voulaient coûte mais
faites vite
voilà madame je suis venu ici pour
sauver ma peau non la police son nom de
ce côté là j'ai rien à craindre bien
pire
mais quoi mais je voulais dit tonio qui
vous veut pas y tient tenez c'est lui
qui a organisé le hold up et qui m'a
obligé à contacter votre mari vous savez
madame mois jusqu'à présent j'avais
jamais participé à une affaire de ce
genre
d'ailleurs l'idée m'en serais même pas
venu mais ça je veux bien vous croire
c'est une idée qui ne vient pas
naturellement retenez quand vous êtes
venu avant-hier soir avec ce beau garçon
oui enfin votre ami paul un ami un ami
si on veut enfin par à titre de beaux
garçons plutôt une relation d'amis à
nous rencontrer la veille
il m'avait l'air vous êtes bien dévoué
il est docteur tu t'énerves à toi pour
un médecin au nom mais je pensais à rien
de mal aux à la bonne heure
ce n'est pas à vous que j'apprendrai que
j'aime mon mari oui aucun mérite je suis
les vieux jeux enfin ne nous égarons pas
votre histoire
et ben si tôt vous évite tout vibre
partie tonio vient d'annoncer tif tiff
fictif là demain pour encaisser ma part
le maquereau en lui qu elle sa mère et
j'ai bon moi je le laisserais vie parce
que j'ai vu là le moyen de casser
malaise tonio il à son pc qui est dans
le bar juste en face de chez moi alors
je devais lui faire le signal sitôt que
l'argent serait là seulement je n'ai pas
fait le signal non j'ai filé en douce
par l'escalier de service jusqu'à demain
à coccinelles amarré rue boursault avec
les 1 million honnêtement gagné pardon
à quoi je vous avais rien demandé et en
plus vous tenait parole parce que votre
mari je l'avais déjà prévenu que perçoit
devoir c'était pas possible
enfin bref avec votre cadeau je me
faisais une vie et une virginité par la
virginité c'est pas une vie
alors qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché mais
bien comme un agneau qui venaient au
partage rue boursault et qui m'a attrapé
juste au moment où je démarre et kan
safra traîné avant le périphérique je
vais la voiture de tonio au train qui a
deux fois il a failli me serrer contrôle
trottoirs rue lafayette et boulevard
barbès il m'a crié par la portière
tu m'a doublé limande je rate beaucoup
plus rouge de bercy julien c mais
reprenant un sens interdit
c'est le qui s'est fait siffler par les
films au matin j'ai roulé toute la nuit
comme une folle et moinard et alors
alors je le sais ma coccinelle porte
d'auteuil avec mes valises puis j'ai
continué à pied en suivant l'était pas
et pourquoi pas reléguée au pont fiche à
l'eau site omnium avait trouvé au oui et
puis vous vous êtes raviser et vous avez
choisi mon appartement comme un cadre
plus ayant pour une mise à mort on est
en madame non mais je tenais surtout à
vous rapporter vos semyon pardon vous me
rapportez mon argent au puisque je les
ai pour gagner alors à mieux la cog réf
ou presque
elle greffe de fresnes parce que c'est
ce qui va faire tenu aussi c'est pas
déjà fait passer un coup de fil aux
flics en dénonçant pour avoir planté un
pauvre vieux tricard qu'il avait choisi
de faire épingler à sa place une fois
coincé en préventive et binche à bonn
pour me retrouver avec une l'homme entre
les deux épaules de tonio il a toujours
des amis de passage dans la maison dans
mon pauvre petit mais cette affreuse que
moi continuerons mais je vais encore
jouer ma chance moi pas de cette ordure
noeuds vitesse y retient neurones moi
mais mon poulet tous nous pour former du
coup ils meurent on a la bonne
je mentirais avec trois ans affronte
vaut le trou mais enfin pour dames
seules au 3o oui le temps d'apprendre
l'espagnol
jane cousine alicante qui tient un petit
commerce qui m'a demandé de venir
l'aider non mais vous êtes fous là
dites-moi est-ce que je peux téléphoner
ou qui est un copain avocats pour qu'ils
passent mais point d qui me conduisent
au caire comme ça les flics qui pourront
pas dire que je me suis pas constituer
librement nom avait été malheureusement
vous voulez que je paye la communication
non
ils vont vous faire parler à
l'instruction ils sont plus forts que
vous il faudra leur expliquer les
raisons de votre beau geste et alors je
serai seul dans le bain avec tonio mais
encore si je peux pas faire autrement
vous ne pouvez pas faire autrement c'est
toute leur rib la sphère d'avant-hier
qui s'étalera dans la presse avec les
noms alors oui ça continue on fait
couler un bain ça tourne vite à la
piscine
ça vous chagrine mais mon mari ne serait
pas dans le bain on va tenir au il
émettrait le pape si ça l'arrangé ah oui
mais il faudra qu'ils puissent me serais
là moi pour le contrer et je dirais que
j'ai jamais vu votre mari ni lui ni sa
bagnole vous verrez l'accent de vérité
cinq ans oui surtout quand le témoin
s'est livré à la justice pour avoir
menti à la police au second alors qu'est
ce que je fais je me laisse physique et
non non rien presse du moins tant que
vous êtes dit si vous n'allez quand même
pas m'adapter
rassurez-vous vous le temps de réfléchir
en attendant vous mettre dans un coin où
personne ne viendra vous chercher même
pas votre mari même pas j'ai là une
petite pièce qui me sert de lingerie je
suis la seule à y mettre les pieds
il a un matelas rouler dans un coin je
vais vous le déplorez a dénoncé ce qui
vous y met un emballage est possible
mais pour le moment c'est moi qui tourne
le robinet allez venez vite vous ne
roulez pas espère non seulement au bord
de la mer tu as dit moi vous feriez
mieux de ranger sa sécheresse qui peut
arriver c'est vrai merci voilà à manama
ce que je peux vous embrasser osé
toujours vous verrez bien re merci merci
mille fois à venir voler par les
adhérentes de fonds
[Applaudissements]
encore c'est à défiler bernard bonjour
françoise je vous dérange
c'était marc cherry ne m'arrangeait pas
non abbas rompe aimable vous m'aviez dit
que votre mari était au bureau jusqu'à
6h les oui mais enfin nous sommes samedi
s'il n'avait pas lui passer chez son
dentiste il serait ici oh mercy falette
ne regrettez rien je les ai volé à la
fleuriste
en la menaçant de mon fils théo la paix
j'en ai profité pour enfin le tiroir
caisse comme ça ne plaisantait pas
jérôme ne devrait pas tarder gilles
invasion qui n'est pas très à l'aise la
présence depuis un an tm et manquerait
plus qu'elle le soit mais quand même
j'aimerais bien le connaître
moi je me tiens en belle curiosité j'ai
passé 50 héros quand ils ne sont pas
aussi pour vous qu'il voyait tous les
jours mais pour un oeil neuf
professionnellement exercé à déceler les
tares les stigmates une énergie encore
beaucoup à faire
je vais me faire une joie de vous
accompagner je porte les paquets comme
un ange j'ouvre les portes hier comme un
dieu je vous rappeler que c'est eux qui
hier à 4 heures que vous deviez
m'appeler sitôt votre mission accomplie
je suis désolé françois sera prévue hier
en rentrant chez moi j'ai trouvé mon
confrère qui m'attendait savez celui que
je dois relever auprès du roi du
manganèse
et bien c'est le moment qu'il avait
choisi pour venir me faire un cours sur
les allergies les syndromes et les
particularités biologiques de notre
illustre patient là 13h45 les deux
heures ça va durer après six heures j'ai
jugé plus prudent de laisser votre
téléphone tranquille je me suis dit que
vous penseriez pas de nouvelle bonne
nouvelle dit d'or vous avez lu les
journaux
la police n'a jugé lui et lui qui est
bine mandrin cartouches que votre mari d
angoisse le petit garçon qui achètent
chez le voisin
c'est pas parce que tu dois quand même
alors quand j'ai été chez la fille hier
elle n'était pas là ni très loin
d'ailleurs parce que sa porte était
ouverte je suis rentré comme dans un
moulin
en tout cas je peux vous affirmer une
chose c'est qu'elle était prête à vous
tenir parole à sa gelée vu ses bagages
été fait et il y avait là un type son
quipe prolongement est qui qui finissait
de les boucler le pas une trop sale
gueule the girl
était plutôt propre à billets comme vous
et moi
enfin surtout comme moi et je lui ai dit
parce que ça m'a frappé c'est joli
franchement on vous donnerait le bon
dieu sans confession
c'est vrai qu'ils ont changé ces
messieurs ils sont plus voyants du tout
maintenant
en tout cas j'ai été très ferme avec lui
et je lui ai dit sans ménagement qui
n'avait plus rien à attendre de cette
aventure alors maintenant je suis
certain que vous n'entendrez plus jamais
parler de rien ni de personne mêlé à
cette histoire c'était la divination et
alors alors je lui ai laissé le porte
documents à remettre vite je sais
c'était léger mais je n'allais tout de
même pas les demandes et a reçus vous
êtes un vrai petit bagage rapport donc
tout de suite après je me suis posté au
coin de la rue boursault pourvoir est
bien la fille est sortie et elle avait
le porte documents alors je vous jure
que je me suis senti mieux je suis
pardonner françoise pas bien si c'est
cet homme de chez elle je ne m'explique
pas avez vous remarqué s'ils avaient des
dents non mais je ne peux pas vous dire
qui m'a sourit tout le temps un mois
c'est long mais c'est important qu'ils
aient des dents en or ah oui ce serait
tonio le chef de l'adq entre les plus
dangereux c'est votre mari qui vous a
dit ça
non je ne raconterai pour le moment
c'est une confidence va garder la 1 le
principal c'est que michel strogoff a
remis le prix du tarn parthenay je vous
rend votre pistolet j'ai pas eu besoin
de m'en servir posez le lac victoria
hélas une autre nouvelle
les jaunards sud meilleur le roi du
manganèse tue pas il a du tout cette
travers dans la journée d'hier parce que
j'ai reçu un coup de fil de l'ambassade
me demandant d'avancer mon départ je
pars mais demain panamerican 01 25
vous en avez de la chance j'ai hâte dans
ces honteuses que vous faites la france
je vous entends encore le dernier jour
ayez fini toutes vos courses de bonheur
je passerai vous dire adieu pas sur ce
tour là assez justement alors raison de
plus bernard ce serait mal d'insister et
bien de travailler votre promesse soit
la transition je vous accompagnerai or
leave a comment une condition c'est
qu'avant vous passiez me prendre au
hilton à cette heure oui un amour au
fond du trou non non au 312 nord ce
n'est qu'au troisième étage que tout
devient féérique vous verrez alors si je
viens je n'aurai pas de regrets ça je
vous jure que non mais qu'est ce que
vont arriver là réclamant résolument
bako des marchés de travaux
voilà quand vous mettez dans ces mails
depuis trois ans je dis à ton qui fera
entrer dans le traité mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait ici il fait passer les
jeunes et court vêtue détail passait
parce que maintenant parce qu'elle vient
de voir si le coeur me dit de ne pas se
presser est jolie et écrit à mon mari
parce qu'il sait qu'elle est ici non et
je ne comptais pas le lui dire non plus
tout ça est d'une clarté aveuglante
alors tâcher de comprendre vite mais
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps donc non
sylvie est comme mon mari oui pauvre
gosse victime du même truands
ces contraintes et forcées qu'elle
travaillait avec un b e-cell et votre
mari c'est contraint et forcé aussi
qu'il a dormi avec elle on me dit moi
que je rêve d'aller vous ans à poudre
est mis à l'eau savonneuse mais
continuez à je comprendrais dans
l'ascenseur elle sylvie sitôt qu'elle a
eus entre les mains autres offrandes
bien femmes et on n'a eu qu'une idée
reprendre sa liberté se refaire une vie
quand vous l'avez vu démarrer dans sa
voiture elle se sauvaient elle tenait
parole mais son gangster ce métier il
l'a prise en chasse enfin elle a réussi
à semer elle est arrivée ici tout à
l'heure en suppliant de la cacher ce que
vous voulez voir el materai pitié bon
ben c'est bien voyageurs c'est grand
c'est généreux ce que vous avez fait là
françois et c'est votre mari qui va pas
s'embêter à katmandou en parisis on
n'est pas d'or jérôme donné deux parties
d'ailleurs je comptais l'envoyer faire
jouer son club de tennis pendant tout le
week end et envoyer la petite en lieu
sûr avant centre avant lequel retour
tonio aura découvert votre charmante
petite protégée
on vous retrouvera toutes les deux
transformé en passoire non je ne crois
pas à deux on peut prendre un tour de
belles pierres pas jérôme n'emporte mais
son revolver mais son fusil de chasse
pour jouer au tennis alors on peut très
bien haut
hors effet katmandou c'est chicago
maintenant c'est plus casanova mitch
koss et en ce qui me concerne plus de
hilton mais françoise aux remparts jeu
du ni de passer ma vie
attendez j'ai mieux à vous offrir je
vais la dénicher votre donzelle et puis
lui faire descendre vos six étages en
catastrophe avec ou sans lesquels tout
non non je ne laissera certainement pas
courir les rues à bord il va tout
arranger
quand vous aurez tout arrangé comme vous
dites vous voulez me faire croire que
vous viendrez me retrouver au hilton au
soir prenez garde sa tournée des
fictions écoutez moi bien là c'est vous
qui m'écoutent et vous allez rester ici
bien ça et vous servir un bon whisky
voilà et moi je vais porter son oreille
à la liste du coup il va dormir 20
heures est tout fait là dont elle avait
plus figure humaine
les tarifs ce que j'en ai vu tout à
l'heure que c'est plus envie que pitié
vous savez emmener là où hilton ça
arrangerait tout en bas bravo françoise
bravo et merci mais quand comprendrez
vous que c'est vous que cher vous seul
vous oui mon dernier jour du condamné
bon alors il ya des jaloux bien d'alcool
un petit peu de musique sont amplement
suffisants pour un con des françoises
écoutez moi je vous en avais pas
sérieusement mais ne me dites pas que
cette petite ne vous a pas tremblé
et des vivres aux yeux comment vous deux
jamais de mémoire mais qu'est ce que
vous allez imaginer un modèle et je ne
pars plus si seulement je pouvais amener
nom de dieu le tueur d'hier
il entre
non
j'en étais sûr que ça traîne réponse
encore qu'il soit pas une douzaine
d'investisseurs français rien non il a
l'air est seul et bassila des
dispositions pour la partie il va être
servir le plat c'est qu'ils ont des clés
pour toutes les portes un sérieux
à
surpris
une vieille connaissance à mais pour ce
que tu veux trop basse par mopar un
geste
ce qui ici le caïd c'est moi
et c'est moi qui pose des questions
enfin lui oui et moi je me remets abrite
au monde
aucune importance c'est quelqu'un qui te
connaissent est debout les mains en
l'air green furie et joue pas petit
soldat un village s'étaient tous deux
roues avec une bastos dans les fûts
mourront
[Musique]
tourne toi abords des bars à rien alors
qu'on venait à être engrais la femme de
sa vie
la non non j'y suis je venais pour
relever les compteurs un débat répond
oui c'est ça j'en ai dit quoi tu mens
puisque des grossistes en fourrure aussi
oui oui un peu macro sur les bonnes gens
c'est des choses à aubry sait que je
suis un peu de la maison à prix est
plutôt bien vu
arabi
la femme pat à bergères l'autre celle
qui crachent ici alors c'est pas un
mythe comme toi que je veux laisser lui
faire des misères toutefois gratter
mâchant vis à l'eau est bas répond ouais
faut baisser les bras
non alors à la fois remercie mais encore
avancé
enlève tes pompes mais quoi répond il
doit comprendre ce que c'est à dire à
mon fils mes chaussures bonne
littérature enlève tes pompes les bras à
rester ponctuent les envois est vite et
routes ne refuse jamais ça attention à
jamais des patins avec des pros tels sap
on sait ce qui tient de mieux oui en
voir à n'ont battu veut que je m'énerve
parfois comprenez moi je fais un régime
honni miami mais je peux faire des trous
vannes ont alors envoyé via et ben
et qu'est ce qu'il
et d'où seulement pour les envois les
bras avec peu d'appuis tout doucement
tu vois quand tu veux tiens le maire de
demain mais voilà donc maintenant il ya
une question qui se pose a pris oui
qu'est ce que je veux faire de toi
aurait pas une idée des fois ne faut pas
trop me demander quand même que donner à
la police offre des vagues de faire
sauter du balcon sa foi des flammes de
cribler ça ferait du bruit que tu sais
que tu deviens je n en ai je m'en rends
compte monsieur ab c'était un homme au
moins tu prends un train pour dieppe ou
être ta études j'ai trés du haut d'une
falaise spontanément comme ça tout le
monde serait content tu vois alors mes
chaussures et mes protégés à la passive
et j'en ai vu qui changeait d'avis avant
il fallait qu il signe un papier en
accusant de plus je le remettrai à la
justice dans la soirée après tu aurais
intérêt à te gommer gentiment savane ou
retard et on ne bouge pas on s'assure
grève pas des rotules ne pas finir ses
jours dans une poussette nova non un
espace ayant pour un cahier de sessegnon
pour perso man ou à tanger une idée
tient rentrer dedans
non merci au nom assez haut nom acide
ah bon
et ne bougent pas la porte à ça j'en
étais sûr que ça travaille pas reese
envie de faire moi je vais faire
sandwich comme une maison maintenant à l
aps le france soir
préparez-vous à l'éblouissement vous
allez mal aux pieds le chevalier ajax
dépose aux pieds d'angélique la
dépouille du dragon ou quoi le chevalier
ajax l'homme est venu et qui l'a pas
retenu les crocodiles ne vais pas de
pépites dans les gencives celui là non
son père son homme de main le sinistre
et douceâtre individus que j'ai lu hier
en train de monter la garde chez sylvie
a mené guêpe et j'étais là tapi dans
l'ombre
retenons mon souffle je les renverser
terrasse est pratiquement réduits à
néant
a nice on le menaçant avec votre
pistolet remarqué parce que ça aide dans
ces cas là est alors sitôt hors d'état
de nuire vous auriez vu ça mais une la
veille
un pleutre et et de la somme abject
vous avez fait enfermé là dedans
la wii ah bravo c'est là qu'on arrive en
son fusil de chasse aux zombies c'est
pas vrai j'oubliais il apparaît chez
l'armurier lundi dernier bon alors je
vais une idée on le fait sortir on lui
parle on lui fait signer sa confession
et on l'envoie chez son patron
dire qu'il a trouvé la petite en valais
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça tout ça moi
par la confession vous pour la
persuasion que le travail des équipes
nous a réussi jusqu'à présent pas vous
êtes sûr qu'il n'est plus d'autres je
voulais tenir les deux bouts
room ah oui
jérôme
mais alors c'est votre mari ma vie
ça ramène attention françoise j'y suis
c'est lui que tu annules les croqueuses
a chargé de mais qu'est ce qui n'est pas
vrai les puisse savoir ce que fait chez
moi ce sondage
tétouan rabat joie que je n'ignore rien
misérable parce que tu es devenu depuis
avant-hier en finlande un chaton dans un
placard mes chaussures à mes bretelles
sur un coussin avec un dingue qui me
disent les tripes comportant en perdant
non gardé le sabre est où vous avez peut
être raison tout s'expliquerait savoir
d'abord un cauchemar je vis un
coup-franc patrie je veux d'abord savoir
ce qui est encore digne de répondre à
mes questions ou si tu n'est plus qu'une
épave a rien de mal je n'ai pas waregem
enfin dans un cauchemar tout est bon
alors pour mon bonheur vous ne perdez
rien pour attendre alors qu'est ce que
tu veux savoir prendre la galathée
réponse un jour a dit vérifier à un
songe à seul et tu sors de ma vie une
solidement encadrée de mesures vers le
dépôt ou vers l'asile selon ton cas
est-ce que tu as commis avant-hier est
ce que peut-être tu t'apprêtes à
commettre ce soir seul le monde mais
alors là je vais voir entrer ben paul
doumer en tutu
maus est dans le viseur
après déjeuner ici même à quelle heure
m'appuie annoncée pour notre rêve entre
6h et 6h30 keller a du coup franc sur
dix neuf des dix neuf 19 maintenant il
est 10 explique et je suis allé
directement chez le dentiste qui m'a
fait poireauter 25 minutes de jeu peut
transiter par coeur le numéro deux jours
de france du 16 octobre 1969
ensuite cet individu le dentiste m'a
attirée par mille câlinerie dans un
grand fauteuil vous pour la modeste
somme de 12 mille anciens francs il a
procédé à l'extraction enfin à
l'arrachement de ma promo leurs
supérieurs go challenge ça fait pas sa
femme et ont ensuite donné je me suis
précipité au bistrot du coin de la rue
de miromesnil élaboré ici où je me suis
jeté un double calvin mais rafa le
bistrot souviendra j'en ai craché la
moitié mais j'avais la colle de peau à
cause de la cocaïne avec des patous
suivent ils ont chassé tout qu'est-ce
qu'on va les faire des films j'avais
qu'une envie revenir ici au calme hop
j'oubliais le taxi qui le ramenait à
côté du chauffeur un caniche blanc
l'accueillant maillotins faire ça
enfin c'est vérifiable je suppose c'est
bien tout non j'ai fait un crochet par
saint flour le temps d'une bourrée elle
en attend plus savoir qui est ce
délicieux inconnu tunnel reconnaît temps
non je n'ai pas visité d'asile
dernièrement et hier je n'ai pas quitté
mon bureau et des personnes
quel culot de catherine alors nous te
fatigue pas jérôme monsieur est un ami
tous les choix c'est bien mais tombe
tout à l'heure il est commis une erreur
très justifiée depuis trois jours il te
sauve la mise
ah bon et à part ça ils en ont le
docteur khan est enchantée médecin
traitant du roi du manganèse
beaucoup de gens pourquoi pas comme ça
énoncé sur trois autant que moi fussent
y compris les grains de beauté et
cessent de faire là à me tu peux parler
devant levy non j'aimerais bien
récupérer mes chaussures ou aller sur le
web rethel mais j'ai les pieds gelés on
assène ont été super non j'ai une
préférence marquée pour mehmad en
sciences françois reinhardt est ici je
te les rapports tu ne sais jamais où les
trouver ma chérie un ample et mettez le
en confiance d'acteur il en a encore
long marathon t il me suis alors trois
mois j'en sais plus à comprendre quoi
que ce soit mais gameiro mais alors où
on prend corps
mon show et moi ça enfin
ce n'est pas moi vous devriez rue des
batignolles et fait vivre pour le dire
j'avais juré à ma femme ne peut avoir
cette petite mais grâce à vous j'ai pas
fini d'entendre parler au coin du feu si
vous ne voudriez pas de réparer et je
vous montrerai tout ce que sait faire
quand on ne me place pas au sol revolver
au poing eh ben j'ai tout compris
oui parce qu'à demi mot sinon j'ai tout
compris là prenez le matelas mais
s'étant même les fourrures sont déjà
bradé un et vous alliez voir tonio les
croqueuses et sa bande pour le partage
ça y est c'est en passant devant chez
sylvie que vous gardez vos adorables
étonnement pour les assises pour les
coins pour les assises parce que moi
j'ai les idées larges plus lorsque votre
malheureuse femme mais directeur dans un
grand ministère au volant fait ça c'est
une couverture fantastique fantastic
four y penser quand même remarqué il ya
un précédent fameux à votre cas c'est
celui de jack l'éventreur en angleterre
qui savent jack l'éventreur angleterre
avis et bien aujourd'hui on sait que de
son vrai nom il s'appelait lors francis
red cliff pairs de la chambre dès lors
il avait la fâcheuse manie des tripes et
une dame ou deux à chaque pleine lune à
jack l'éventreur
voilà d'un jeune j'étais de saillé jack
l'éventreur alors la police avaient
toutes les preuves du monde mais aucune
raison de le soupçonner
aba'a l'ordre en love alors il est mort
de sa belle mort en emportant dans sa
tombe
son fâcheux chromosome y avoir que pour
vous c'est moins grave
ah bah tant mieux mais pas eu l'occasion
ces temps derniers des tripes et une
dame ou de à la pleine lune voleuse papa
récemment
non ça c'est pas trouvé faut vous dire
je sors très classe et ça en tout cas
vous n'avez pas l'air d'avoir du sang
sur les mains mais quand même je crois
qu'il vaudrait mieux ne pas trop vous
contrarié par une nuit de pleine lune et
même sans lui répondre mais non ce à
quoi lui ou autres villes et la part mon
dieu ma l'orne dans le fond de la
corbeille alain tu me dira que c'est
moins grave telle date je dirais sans
nom mais nous en parlerons mieux ça
vaudra
mais néanmois tu fais comme les
apportera des pantoufles à la santé du
salon madame until bien sage de le
pousser à bout de temps mais c'est plus
fort que moi d'ailleurs je vous dois une
confession tout à l'heure je suis fort
et le doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'au coude à
saâles à flêtre j'aurais juré mais n'est
le nom à non en regardant votre mari de
plus près je peux vous affirmer que ça
n'est pas l'homme que j'ai vu hier rue
des batignolles
tu vois ma chérie il ya une ressemblance
non non et non il ya aucune aucune
ressemblance entre autres choses l'homme
que je veuille y ramener les oreilles en
chou-fleur relève mais vous ne dites pas
ça pour me faire plaisir non mais
j'espère que ça revient au même
bah oui évidemment je ne pouvais pas le
dire si machin j'ai présenté mes excuses
à monsieur qui a bien voulu les accepter
il n'aurait plus manqué que ça après
tout ce qu'il vous doit oui c'est vrai
bon bah dans ce cas je crois qu'on peut
lui dire oui pardon ici
quel os en tant que l'on ne fait pas
l'innocent et surtout l'espère peut rien
les petits extras se terminer met toi
bien ça dans la tête là mon dieu c'est
parce que tu as quel courant je suppose
je suppose que oui
bon ben non c'est préfère y aller moi
mais vous êtes fous mais enfin vous
savez bien qu'il n'ya pas de serrure
pour ces types là alors qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'ils anticipent du coup
ils seront 2 non je vais dire que la
police et la police à 6 ils assistent
tire à travers notre patience pour en
découdre ce second toi toi bon geste à
sa maîtrise et la police il te plaît car
je sois passé ma journée dans closer
madame monsieur inspecteurs de la police
judiciaire podio
enchanté les spectateurs ni mon mari le
docteur carnet un ami de mon mari
je lui montrais estampillé fondeur sur
ce petit bronze et remettez fichtre à
clodion une aux rapporteurs chercher les
collections volet nous devenons
connaisseurs mais il n'ya pas d'objets
volés et l'inspecteur affirmation
téméraire madame qui le dit n'en sais
rien qui le signe du rire
et
puisqu'ils portent aux indiens qui
vivent pas mais sinon amis c'est presque
jamais bons vins servis en ont jamais
plus court alors
quel bon format mais non peu de choses
dans la mine une enquête a bouclé un
drame dans les mains mais non ailleurs
un vol à main armée en place est vilain
excusé
soignez vos souffrances si vous ne
semblez pas bien vaillant je vais jouer
au docteur auprès de vous non non non
rien de bien sérieux non quelque chose
qui ne passe pas rien de bien sérieux
rien de bien sérieux
je l'envoyais au lit quand vous êtes
entré dormir debout peut-être
j'espère que vous n'allez pas trop mal
fatigué aujourd'hui au look est
maintenant terminée docteur il n'y
manque plus que les arrestations et
approuvé un monsieur jérôme dormoy que
la police française n'est jamais égaré
bien non monsieur désiré vous que je
recueille votre déposition ce la seule
raison d'être mais dites moi j'ai hâte
d'être éclairée et bien c'est à vous
permettez madame c'est bien monsieur
jérôme dormoy directeur de l'orientation
au ministère du travail
la fois juste et aujourd'hui je n'en
avais jamais douté vous êtes bien un
possesseur de la voiture automobile
numéro 7284 jm je sens qu'un chat vous
monsieur dormoy oui monsieur dormoy
j'étais chargé de l'enquêté concernant
le hold up des entreprises du grand nord
dans la nuit du 17 au 18 de ce mois
redisons avant avant-hier or tous les
compliments aussi dans notre industrie
comme moi vous n'êtes pas pour rien dans
cette affaire est bien racontée mois ci
la plaisanterie suit sa courbe je
montrais à l'échafaud commun qui parlent
trop et on sait forcément l'impression
madame
enfin nous ne voulons pas la mort du
pécheur alors là c'est un footeux c'est
kafka ans - miyem et en plus qu'un lent
monsieur d'envoi sur le tabac était
monté par un vieux cheval de retour
antonio carpaccio dit tonio les
croqueuses nous avons dû l'agencé hier
dans l'après-midi des bergues et l'un de
ses complices qui s'est à peine fait
prier pour passer aux aveux alors je
suis ici pour vérifier ses dires et par
voie de conséquence vous poser une
question feu
vous avez été agressé le 17 au matin
boulevard de la madeleine par une jeune
personne du nom de sylvie moore
domiciliés 147 rue des batignolles non
je n'ai pas été accostée inspecteurs ah
non j'ai heurté demont et l'avant une
jeune femme qui n'en demandait pas tant
je suis descendu pour m'excuser et
m'assurer qu'elle n'avait aucun match à
aubeterre tout cas n'a eu aucun mal à
vous faire accepter de venir dîner chez
elle le soir ma rage traitement de voir
signé il ya les conclusions d'un tel
qu'il se manifeste comme après les huit
raids allende rue madame pas incidemment
nous cherchons activement sylvie move
pour complicité dans le hold-up et pour
la prévenir que mieux vaudrait pour elle
de ce livre est que de tomber dans les
pattes de tokyo les croqueuses qui court
encore
enfin en amour pour lui sauver la vie la
pauvre fille mais quelle horreur vous
avez empêché sens magna mais vous avez
vous pu m'intéresser à l'inspecteur
aussi et human d'inspecteurs vous l'avez
vu cette jeune femme mais nous avons sa
photo elle est tout fichier non non non
rien de bien terrible non un truand
planqué chez elles que nous cherchions
n'ont pas de rancune l'équipe était
innocent c'était cappuccio qu'avec ont
pillé de la faire tomber
je crois que le voile se déchire alors
profitons-en
car j'aimerais revenir à ce qui vous
concerne monsieur non mais vous semblez
son corps ignorer que la fille monde
avait manigancé cet accident pour faire
votre connaissance et de fil en aiguille
vous attirer dans la soirée à son
domicile
je n'ai aucun plaisir à l'apprendre
d'abord à la fusée catégoriquement ma
modeste offrandes
bon ce n'est ni mon pardon on l'attend
qu'elle m'avait consacré mais ce détail
est flatteur pour vous ah non non non
non non
sa mission était tout autre à tirer
votre voiture devant son domicile et la
rendre disponible pour le hold up du
rendement c'est facile à dire ça aux de
monsieur dans moi le complice de
karoutchi ou agace juillet comme un
petit chanteur à la croix de bois
mais pourquoi marc burg à la longueur
d'un grattoir dans les rues de la
capitale oui mais 20 seulement de la
marque et des caractéristiques de la
vôtre indispensable pour mettre en
confiance le veilleur de nuit
eh bien monsieur dans moi une chose me
taquinent moi mon mari n'était pas dans
la voiture
specter je suis prête elle jure est
regrettable madame car comment le seriez
vous non mais vous avez votre faux
témoignage à tous les mérites d'un vrai
notre petit chanteur à la croix de bois
nous a fourni la liste de tous les
complices de tonio les croqueuses mais
voici qui est plus ennuyeux pour vous
monsieur dormoy entre travaux j'ai
appris seulement hier soir que notre
petit chanteur avait été chargé de
ramener votre voiture n'ont vu des
bateaux mais devant votre domicile
oui on s'en doute pour ne pas mettre la
fille move dans le bas autant qu'il se
pouvait alors vous avez donc été le
premier à découvrir le vol
au sortir de votre produit
de votre entretien avec cette jeune
personne oui ou non pardonnez moi madame
mais votre mari a insisté pour que vous
soyez présentes à cette conversation
les plus instructifs pour moi que vous
ne le pensez et alors et ben voilà
la première chose que fait
immanquablement et sur le champ le
propriétaire d'une voiture volée c'est
de téléphoner à la police afin de se
couvrir vis-à-vis de son assurance sa
votre premier mouvement réguler
normalement être de vous précipiter dans
la cabine téléphonique du bistrot le
plus proche ou au commissariat cloisons
ça en ne faisant pas vous avez entraver
la marche de la justice
et c'est précisément là dessus que
compté tenu aux voitures s serait sur
les sollicitations de de la filmo
inspecteurs j'ignorais ce qui était
advenu de ma voiture un homme marié
entraverait la marche d'une division
blindée
si ça pouvait empêcher sa femme de se
demander ce qu'il faisait entre entre 9
heures et minuit rue des batignolles au
madame dix ans de métier mon abri qui
l'y a dit menteur marier pour un
célibataire et combien de criminels sur
son directeur au ministère du travail
c'est intelligent ça
comment savoir docteur fait on nous
retire beaucoup d' enquête
enfin quoiqu'il en soit je ne donne
aucune chance à monsieur dormoy pour une
carrière criminelle prometteuse
cet inspecteur bon et bien voici en tout
cas mon enquête agréablement terminé à
la fois ci une enquête les jamais obtenu
dans une affaire aussi sun que celle-ci
il démarre à fait curieux bas qui
d'ailleurs ne vous concerne en rien
monsieur d'armoires et bien août où la
victime a été dans votre voiture
et pendant ce raid sur les manuellement
complètement dépouillé de ses vêtements
oui on s'est même ce qui nous a permis
d'ajouter fois aux aveux du complice de
tonio bas où nous avons trouvé ses
vêtements sur un bas côté du pré catelan
juste à l'endroit où il nous l'avait
indiqué et puis un drop que lorsque nous
avons retrouvé le diu encore évanoui à
il était à nouveau venu de la tête aux
pieds
voyez vous ça commence ici c'est très
intéressant les combats auraient pu le
banal absolument pas identifiable et dit
qu'elle t'enlever mais pur cachemire au
pour tout indice une manche se
trouvaient au coude droit et rafistolé
tant bien que mal sur youtube sans
plaisir aux nombreux photographes
monsieur l'inspecteur est sans précédent
mais je finis donc je finis le fini et
un pantalon de sport bleu canard sans
étiquette également et à ses usagers
le seul signe distinctif un stockage oui
oui oui instant pages à ce tapage au
genou gauche une poche la pièce ou non
mais vous voyez toujours le même petit
mystère pas insignifiant mais à celui
est tellement passionnant n'est ce pas
ma chérie moi tout seul mois les romans
policiers
j'en prends je reste je raccompagne
merci mais de voir monsieur j'espère ne
pas vous avoir trop fait ou inspecteur
est tellement intéressé c'est bon 6 la
santé qui retient
et vous docteur comment vous sentez-vous
roumaine j'attends quoi mon chéri mon
pull en cachemire trouvaient au coude
mon pantalon bleu kahn a stoppé au genou
al'approche rapiécé et ben oui c'est moi
toi tu quoi à qui ai donné les frusques
28 pourquoi à la victime pour te sauver
on me trouver de quoi manger quand une
femme en rentrant chez elle à vue dans
un fourré dubois un homme pratiquement
nue éjectée d'une voiture tous feux
éteints et qu'il a identifié la voiture
de son mari son devoir n'est-il pas de
ramener chez eux le pauvre bougre pour
l'empêcher si possible d'aller raconter
son histoire à la police je ne crois pas
me souvenir que tu me montrer un homme
nu quand je suis arrivé ramener à son
point de chute après certitude qu'il
n'avait pas pu relever le numéro de la
voiture est habillée avec les affaires
j'espère qu'il a remercié sa femme dans
leur tombe dans les pommes
à boncourt matraque et parfois grâce à
des insomnies nous avons de quoi
endormir à cheval ici voilà maintenant
cela brazillier
[Musique]
et javier des affaires pour qu'ils ne
prennent pas fois oui et aussi les
brouiller un peu les idées au réveil
donc c'est un jury sans vous achetez
savent ou non mais j'ai eu à subir
dernièrement une perte assez pénible
après à ces risques est plutôt une leçon
n'avait surprise acteur ça on avait
surpris les dents françoise y pense t-on
éjecté c'est dans un fourré dubois que
tu l'a cueilli là ou ailleurs
oui mais je doute que tu les ramener
celui-ci puis reportée à son point de
départ
j'étais en haïti paris en taxi peut-être
et le chauffeur s'est fait un plaisir de
te rendre ce léger sérieuses et rabat
non non ce n'était pas de son ferr ville
entière trouver quelqu'un pour me
raccompagner un de leurs invités c'est
ça qui s'est fait une joie de te prêter
main forte
il ya des gentlemans partout de pauvres
gens y aurait-il un ici sans compter
jal est le pire ne te retient pas eh
bien oui
alors voulez-vous me dire ce que vous
foutez en bagnole dans les ténèbres d'un
four et du bois quand le chemin de
meudon à la vie de versailles pas soit
deux bons kilomètres de long jeanne on
parle de kilos mais il ne va pas dans ce
pays une semaine normale presque avait
du brouillard peut-être géant justement
et du fezzan ses clients du sud c'est
même ça tu sais je sais je sais aussi
que pour contempler le clair de lune
préfecture des lacs on allonge les
hippodromes on s'enfonce pas dans la
jungle on sur tapis pendant les fous et
je saurai pour voir arriver une voiture
sur la pointe des pieds tout faisait à
bâle en 5 par la portière repartir
s'éloigner avoir le temps de noter son
numéro faut être pris dans les glaces
avis contraire d'en écouter même utile
je sais aussi que dans une voiture à
l'arrêt savait pas une question de vie
ou de mort de tenir les deux mains
crispées sur le volant ne savent pas ce
risque est réel mais en vain de charité
comme vous étiez et comme une main
droite ignorer ce que fait l'autre on
n'a pas trop des deux pour reconnaître
le terrain d'angers roma tu oublies que
pendant ce temps-là tu taquinait la
langouste et les belons sur l'ordi aaa à
aa
et vous vous mettiez découvert
non le talion l'effet ben les oiseaux
mouches c'est exact je rencontrais le
docteur chez nos amis et je les trouvais
fort séduisant je veux plus
ça n'enlève rien mais lui non plus j'ai
trouvé charmant qui n'aura campagne tu
m'avais la cour travail et humblement il
a souhaité faire un détour par le bois
je n'ai pas été contre qu'il avait à
venir
c'était tout de même plus agréable que
la rue quincampoix le passage choiseul
évoluer même promis de lui dire au
revoir demain soir salle m'ennuyer pas
et de plus ça va donner un délicieux
avant-goût de remords
le reste de l'histoire tu le connais un
conte de fées changer un roman policier
pour l'amour de toi ici tu n'es pas
content c'est pareil
après tout la consolation d'une épouse
fidèle et de s'imaginer veuve de temps
en temps non mais dites non mais tu veux
que je les embrasse non vous devez avoir
sa part exempt de raymond boyer aussi
dans cette histoire je ne vous connais
pas vous ne m'avez jamais sauvé la vie
me prêter d'argent
françoise et votre forme d'accords mets
salés par mois que vous aimeriez
d'ailleurs en étant en général contre le
mariage était logique avec moi même en
étant contre le vôtre bon j'y ajouterai
ce depuis trois jours je sue sang et eau
pour vous sauver du bagne alors si vous
n'êtes pas content je suis pas vous
donner réparation mais en homme
d'honneur qui s'en va demain pour trois
ans en australie alors il faut faire
vite
qu'est ce que vous diriez d'une
explication à la mexicaine d'accord
c'est quoi ça bon c'est pas compliqué un
mouchoir et de couteaux d'égal longueur
de préférence à chacun un bout du
mouchoir et nous croisons le faire
jusqu'au premier de nous deux qui large
le mouchoir pittoresque
non ils font ça les mexicaines
ils font ça les mexicains qui doivent
pas s'embêter je ne sais pas mais ils
font ça il ya une chose que je retiens
de votre proposition il acquiert et
parfois n'ya non non le mouchoir sur
nous ferons une joie ma femme et moi de
venir l'agité demain au libre écoute
alors vous me mettez les larmes aux yeux
à passer l'épongé serrez vous la trouve
et vous vraiment content d'en avoir fini
arrêté sur pauliste
je vous je peux bien si c'est la petite
amie maintenant ah bon ce que j'ai dormi
moi maman je suis refait une beauté
regardez-moi ça aille mieux non allez on
va les laisser un peu bavarde équipe le
rallye
donc vous que vous qui êtes docteur vous
comprenez mieux je sais alors c'est une
très grave causant euros qui m'a bien
mieux oui monsieur avait mis du compte
ou non et elle c'était sous la menace
n'a écouté mon vieux de tout ce qui
s'est passé ici depuis quatre jours la
télé tirerait au moins un an de
feuilleton x
là je vous fais un résumé télégraphique
vous me suivez
sylvie au fripouille gentil ni stop
épouvanté par menace de son jules
accepte fuir loin d'ici ce tome
subventionné par françoise pour
l'éloigner de booster pays où quand chez
elle est fière suite suivez mon suit
vous soyez gentil hein sait déjà c'est
déjà assez compliqué comme ça
alors oui je sais bien alors justement
on se fixe et on le suit on se met à
l'heure sylvie poursuivi par tueur qui
veulent empêcher de parler vient se
réfugier ici dit stop
attendrie françoise la cache stop
craignant arrivée imminente du tueur
stop vous ayez envie hier chez elle vous
prend pour lui ce temps pour le tuer
pour le bébé
c'est flatteur mais je sais bien à ce
qui se comprend bien il peut encore se
présenter le toit oui mais maintenant on
est deux à l'idéal serait qu'on soit 12
ça je sais bien que ça c'est bon elle
est ravissante oui j'oubliais ravissante
et merveilles
ah bon pourquoi elle a remporté l'argent
vers mars et pour cause comme tout le
monde mais en tant qu alors j'en rate
pas voilà le mien il montre la chanteuse
donne
leur vie s'ils dans l'argent mon argent
est le sien vase et ça c'est lumineux
qui conducteur non appelez-moi bernard
hinault dr bernard
oui faites moi un grand plaisir ne
m'expliquer plus rien après tout je
reviens je lui trouve une robe place est
né dans un état oui alors un truc
formidable mais je crois qu'elle serait
d'accord
[Rires]
[Musique]
d'accord sur quoi comment voulez vous
que je le sache
1 vous avez épousé un labyrinthe alors à
sa série était féerique donnant le mot
est faible
c'est bernard ce matin je n'avais pas
bravo mais complément des doors françois
c'est quand même pas rien africains
attendus mais françoise fini ou sylvie
commence c'est moins bien que vous et
croyez que je rendrais ont suivi sylvie
une loutre apprivoiser des lèvres qui
semble dans la bouche des dessins qui
vous regarde dans les yeux et lui
dassier une invention il ya des grandes
sont des petites secondes lacunes rails
dans la joie quoi
des dons ça vous en aurez pas parler
d'autre chose
pourquoi vous êtes frigide je ne serais
pas ici des cheveux des poils et
vaccinés c'est vraiment parti on croyait
pas et on vend pas pop
vous savez docteur qu'il est très
intéressant à ses heures et de bons
conseils je crois volontiers les petites
retraites
l'essai va garder oui à lui sans cette
petite bonne femme avant tout contraire
de ce qu'on pourrait quoi égarer oui des
voiliers encore non je n'ai manière
l'élégance du coeur desquelles est en
confiance et à notre propos son rêve
tricoter des pulls cuisiner de bons
petits plats
tenir un petit me via je vis bien
douillet pour un homme intelligent du
cac qui saura se faire aimer écouter
françoise vous êtes très magnanime un
votre mari aussi d'ailleurs il m'a dit
des choses sur elle
mené des choses tout à son honneur on y
voit juste à ses heures le sagouin alors
imaginez cette petite et tremblay tués
cette nuit demain à paris brûle tout
coin d'une rue à la morgue sur une dalle
défiguré hommes et qu'elles envoient
heureusement heureusement je crois
qu'elle serait d'accord je me déjà dit
mais d'accord sur quoi prouver
eh bien d'abord elle le trouve beau
garçon tu as tes les gens charmants et
tout en bas deux et puis il est médecin
ça la pression terrible
oui et alors vous ne voyez pas j'essaye
de ne pas voir sans doute mais moi je te
le conseille un
françoise unis au plafond soit jamais eu
françois pour vous je veux dire on
écoute et bernard genoud devriez être le
premier à savoir que je n'aurais jamais
envoyé giroul trois jours au tennis
uniquement pour venir vous faire la bise
au hilton
vous savez la brute d'ici là pis non
mais rassurez-vous jérôme abadie chef
des propos relayés en tout bien tout
honneur au l'honneur dans ces cas-là à
la baisse que j'aurais fait du y avez
droit
mais rappelez-vous une chose mon ami
plus une autre femme promet mois il
tient ainsi qu'aux mais j'ai pris le
grand larousse moi ce matin mais la page
australie elle est jolie la page
d'australie il est à croquer la page
australie ont la brousse ceci on se
promène le désert si on se perd la neige
si on grimpe des serpents tigre derrière
chaque calyptus et des reptiles venimeux
dans les branches et des sauvages à
l'âge de pierre
ivres morts la plupart du temps pour
combler les vides et je vous assure que
melbourne en dix ans les enfants et tu
torride hiver glacial sécheresse ou
déluge métallurgie et chantiers navals
non là je crains que tu es mal j'ai lu
comme il faut entre les lignes
et alors pour la bagatelle le
marivaudage un habitants au kilomètre
carré
et pas forcément une femme obligés de se
rabattre sur les kangourous vous sur les
on les bouffes bête
mais pourtant je me suis laissé dire le
droit d'être en dehors des
professionnels du port quelques
créatures possible mais des gens en main
cadenassé l'ombre d'un regard sur ces
mignonnes et vous vous retrouvez avec la
voix de lily pons le poste que je le
souhaite
au lieu de ça au lieu de ça vous arrivez
dans ce bled de mahler avec une belle
petite bien à vous qui se doit la vie
qui ne demande qu'à aimer a mérité de
l'être
imaginez vous dans un mac ou sous 3
édredon selon leur rafraîchi vous
réchauffer de caresses ingénieux oui je
suis censé arriver seul au but qu'ils un
petit bonnet à croix rouge sur sa tête
une blouse blanche sur ses chars votre
assistante dévouée et compétente à
offrir au fond elle a raison une fois le
danger passé vous nous la renvoyer on
lui trouvera bien quelque chose
on s'est souhaité me trouve mais dites
moi il ya le visa ni à l'épicurien vous
oubliez de chopard demain mais oui vous
partez en mission officielle appelée de
toute urgence
vous n'avez trouvé une infirmière qu'à
la dernière minute tout s'arrangera à
l'aéroport même comme ça elsa votre avis
et papa le tien
oh la la la la la merci dites-moi est-ce
qu'il est d'accord ça ma chérie demandé
le nom françois joseph avons fait pas
nous
dr lô
françoise je tombe au précipice où le
destin m'appelle on dirait du corps
neige et du corps et les merveilleuses
non je dis pas que tu es tu auras joie
bien marignan l'eau elle vise à poser
une question voulu opposer quatre
répondait je veux bouche les oreilles
pour ne pas entendre
mais enfin on dit un mot de trois
lettres qui commence pas au haut oui oui
bravo bernard tu ne dis rien gougeard
seul le silence est grand pour le reste
est faible
bon fils et maintenant vous pouvez en
avoir des choses à vous dire avant le
départ tenez l'oublié parfois oui vous
jetterez un coup d'oeil ça se passait
bien ceux de sylvie vous êtes sûr que
vous ne regrettez rien et ça me changera
mais alors j'aime beyene ses tracks j'ai
jamais pris l'avion
non si on m'avait dit que mon baptême de
l'air j'ai en australie mais comme
infirmière du roi du manganèse ils
savonnent ne riez pas cru mais pour quoi
que ce soit d'extraordinaire c'est pas
au revoir françoise au revoir et merci
pour tout vous savez vous avez une femme
formidable
ciao
et n'oubliez pas demain au lieu de rim
promet
bon et bien au revoir françoise avoir
bernard
oui ça va
allô oui oui oh non certainement pas
monsieur phentex c'est la maison prunier
mais pas du tout et c'est de la folie
douce je vous dit nous n'avons jamais
commandé d'imagerie ses mémoires et
comme un des moments
chacun son tour à l'eau oui 8 heures ça
sera parfait
merci caviar filet de sole d'autun
kochman bas ça changera
tu n'es pas content of c c'est une
merveilleuse idée que veux tu mon pauvre
gérer il faut se faire une raison
là aussi le wi fi ni
mesdames messieurs la pièce que nous
venons de jouer pour vous ce soir est de
jean-jacques bricaire et maurice la sec
les décors sont de roger à
avec danielle darrieux
jean pierre darasse
henri poirier
avec dany carrel
bernard typhaine
nos amis
la mise en scène est de michel roux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]